Bruno just give me a sense of are you
worried that the markets are not worried
about what's happening in Greece and the
fact that we could still fifty-fifty
chance on whether we get an agreement or
not today well I think we have a good
chance to have an agreement because of
the developments in the Greek situation
last last week you know Greek people are
voted against their government it's not
a formal vote but when they withdraw
cash from their bank bank banking
account it's a kind of way of saying we
don't trust this government any longer
so maybe mr. tsipras remains very
popular in opinion polls but last week
Greek people showed that there was
another Greece not willing to be to have
any interest in this government in
longer and so this makes domestic
pressure on mr. cheapest and his
government to to reach a deal and I
think that the official creatures and
the IMF and the ECB have been very clear
that is the last the last chance for
them to get a fair deal yeah but we know
are you concerned though that the
markets are brushing over this i mean if
you look at the impact I know this may
be contained I understand that this is
maybe just for Greece you know it's a
problem of credibility in Europe it's a
problem of how we deal with the next
country that wants to negotiate tough
and rough as well you know why are these
markets on the upswing well it's an
uncertainty and markets don't like
uncertainty but I want to stress
something in my view very important you
know three years ago the last time we
considered seriously the possibility of
a grexit the difference the gap between
Greece and the second weakest link in
the eurozone was very small today the
second weakest country in the eurozone
is Portugal but Portugal is growing
Portugal as implemented reforms and so
the gap between Greece and the second
weakest country in Europe is very very
large so
or in a way we could say well maybe
markets are are too too too much upset
with this with this question because the
risk of contagion it exists but i think
is very very small specially if we
compare with the situation 33 years ago
and a big big change in the meantime is
the fact that the ECB is no is now
prepared to to out any contagion to make
sure that the risk of denomination is
not is not there basically the ECB has
unlimited firepower to to purchase bonds
from other countries so maybe markets
underestimate this this new feature in
the in the in the Greek crisis um Bruno
do we need debt restructuring and
actually how painful will that be greek
debt restructuring one way or another i
think that we don't know exactly what
kind of deal will be signed but i think
it's fair to say that today greek debt
is unsustainable so i don't think that
we will add a right we will have a right
off that I think that the official
creatures are prepared to set them to
the Greek government we may in the
future as this as they said in the past
we may in the future consider maybe
lengthening of the the majority and be
increasing the grace period for Greece
not to pay interest I think this is a
possibility so I don't know if you want
you to call it a restructuring but I
think it's part it's part of the deal
and my understanding of the recent
statements by the IMF and Europe is that
it's a it's a possibility to to be in
this deal um Bruno are you confident
that we'll get something today or this
week or does it doesn't matter so much
as long as it's before the 30th
I sorry I didn't get a question do you
think that we will get a deal today a
deal on green oh yes I think so I oh yes
I think we will have because you know we
don't know exactly the amount of cash we
which is withdrawn from banks that we
add various Press reports and maybe it
was a 1.7 billion friday maybe 1 billion
this morning it's clear that at this
pace of cash withdrawal the banking
sector could collapse in the next few
days so this is basically the main
pressure on the on the Greek government
to to to to sign the deal i think the
IMF and the European creatures are
willing to to to to at this deal now
it's it's Greece move so with the new
new pressure on them as i said the fact
that greek people are voting against
their government the fact that they are
we throwing a cash at a very very high
pace every day in the past few days the
situation is not sustainable any longer
so it's a it's today or collapse of the
banking sector and probably with the
collapse of the banking sector the fact
the government will be forced to impose
capital control and provider the
government will not survive this kind of
measures